[Musik]
simon moroney
matthias sammer
[Musik]
nur weniges erinnert an die zeit vor 15
jahren als hier in srebrenica der
bosnienkrieg seinen traurigen höhepunkt
fand serbische truppen nahmen die
mehrheitlich von bosnien bewohnte stadt
ein vertrieben zehntausende und
ermordeten etwa 8000 jungen und männer
viele werden bis heute vermisst fünf
kilometer außerhalb von srebrenica hier
in portugal lag der ehemalige stützpunkt
der vereinten nationen
tausende bossen ja flohen hierher sie
hofften auf schutz bei einem bataillon
niederländischer blauhelme vergeblich
denn diese verhinderten das morden nicht
diese bastion hat eine stärke von 350
mann gehabt damit gegen eine mahalla von
etwa einer division stärke mit panzern
und artillerie zu kämpfen ist purer
selbstmord selbst wenn sie das getan
hätten hätten sie auf die dauer die
menschen in srebrenica nicht schützen
können und so sind es heute die
identifizierten opfer des massakers von
srebrenica die man hier nach porto cervo
überführt dieses jahr werden so viele
beigesetzt wie noch nicht 775 männer und
jungen
zurück bleiben die überlebenden die
abschied nehmen von ihren brüdern vätern
und söhnen die meisten von ihnen sind
nur einmal im jahr in srebrenica
anders hat die armee so wie sie ist
zurückgekehrt
seit acht jahren lebt sie nun wieder
hier ihr schicksal sie muss dieses jahr
ihre beiden söhne und ihren ehemann
beerdigen
slobodan milosevic der serbische
präsident war ist der die serben in
jugoslawien 1989 ein schwur auf einen
heiligen krieg
sein ziel die errichtung eines groß
serbischen reiches auf dem balkan schon
bald rollten panzer erst in slowenien
und kroatien und dann in bosnien die
schlagkraft der serbischen verbände war
denen der bosnier überlegen um den
bosnischen serben unter die arme zu
greifen
also ich würde schon als aggressions
krieg der serien bezeichnen man hat eine
armee aufgebaut man halt sehr viele
offiziere der jugoslawischen armee in
dem serbischen raum gehabt die man
genutzt hat man hat kaum gruppe gehabt
und die truppe hat die jugoslawische
armee nachgeschoben die samen haben ja
klar erklärt sie wollten entweder in die
usa ziehen bleiben oder ihren eigenen
serbischen staates innerhalb bosniens
gründen das war hoch problematisch weil
innerhalb bosniens keine einzige
gemeinde ethnisch homogen war
wer kein serbe war musste gehen
ethnische säuberung nannte man das
dahinter verbergen sich systematische
vertreibung und ermordung der terror
richtete sich gegen die bosnische
zivilbevölkerung vor allem muslime der
serbenführer radovan karadzic und
general ratko mladic war es die in
bosnien die verbrechen planten und
steuerten wir wissen heute dass die
sogenannten ethnischen säuberungen das
heißt die planmäßige vertreibung der
nicht serbischen zivilbevölkerung von
langer hand vorbereitet und auch
systematisch durchgeführt worden ist
hat jedoch schon 1993 dauerte der krieg
in bosnien bereits zwei jahre
der großteil des bosnischen territoriums
lag in serbischer hand so auch das
gebiet um srebrenica mehr als 60.000
menschen flüchteten in die stadt und der
französische un general philippe
morillon versprach schutz rief sie zur
un-schutzzone aus einzige bedingung die
eingeschlossenen mussten ihre waffen
abgeben sich unter den schutz der
vereinten nationen stellen
ein holländisches bataillon schlecht
ausgerüstet sollte srebrenica
verteidigen
der hauptschuldige ist die uno denn die
uno hat eine un sicherheitsresolution
herausgegeben hat gesagt es wird eine
schutzzone ohne zu sagen das bedeutet
dass und ohne genügend soldaten hin zu
stellen mit dem auftrag die menschen
dort auch wirklich zu schützen
der auftrag des niederländischen barrios
war im grunde genommen nur dann zu den
waffen zu greifen wenn sich selbst
angegriffen werden das heißt nur zum
selbstschutz waffen zu graben im juli
1995 droht im laden stehen un truppen
die stadt einzunehmen
der holländische kommandant forderte
luftunterstützung an doch die un lehnte
ab serbische verbände eroberten die
schutzzone ohne gegenwehr vor den augen
der un soldaten begann der völkermord
hinter stacheldraht überließen die
un-soldaten die menschen von srebrenica
ihrem schicksal
es begann die selektion tausende frauen
und kinder wurden nun in überfüllte
busse gepfercht
sie sollten in sicherheit gebracht
werden auf bosnisch kontrolliertes
gebiet tage lang dauerte die deportation
verzweiflung machte sich breit
das schicksal der männer war ungewiss
viele hofften vergeblich dass auch sie
abtransportiert würden sie mussten
bleiben und viel in den serben schutzlos
in die hände
dieselben führten die jungen und männer
in die umliegenden wälder
dann begann das morden die leichen
verschleppt und verscharrt
sabrina wurde zum synonym für den
völkermord an den muslimen in bosnien
genozid bedeutet im unterschied zu
anderen verbrechen die absichtsvolle
vernichtung von angehörigen einer
volksgruppe und die vernichtung die
absicht eine volksgruppe als solche zu
vernichten
in srebrenica ist dieser tatbestand
ziemlich gut nachzuweisen aufgrund von
zahlreichen zeugenaussagen aufgrund der
exhumierung und forensischen
untersuchungen ist klar dass diese
vernichtungs absicht bestand in
massengräbern verscharrt
die serbischen soldaten die opfer ihres
verbrechens über 30 existieren alleine
in der region srebrenica und immer
wieder werden neue durch hinweise aus
der bevölkerung entdeckt
massen gräben sind liberal und bis heute
es gibt keine richtige geständnis von
diejenige die genozid getragen das ist
das schlimmste
wir haben ein lose teile von gericht in
den haag aber keine keine wirkliche
geständnis und das ist schmerzhaft und
die ganze bevölkerung
das mobiliar in einer alten lagerhalle
auf dem ehemaligen un stützpunkt von
porto jerry erinnert ein museum an die
opfer des massakers 4500 etwa wurden bis
heute beigesetzt
der jüngste der ermordeten war gerade
erst zwölf oft sind es nur ein paar
gegenstände die von ihnen übrig blieben
erinnerungen an hand die ira die
hinterbliebenen der toten
familienangehörigen identifizieren
[Musik]
im gedenkzelt rum von tarifen jährlich
die beisetzungen der opfer des
völkermordes statt der elfte juli er ist
von der europäischen union zum gedenktag
des massakers von srebrenica ausgerufen
worden
jahr für jahr nehmen hier die
angehörigen abschied von ihren toten für
die hinterbliebenen bleiben nur schmerz
und das unverständnis wie durch
menschenhand so etwas geschehen konnte
zeitgleich erreicht der friedensmarsch
srebrenica aus allen städten bosniens
machen sich teilnehmer auf den weg
unter ihnen auch überlebende des
massakers tausende versuchten damals den
serben zu entkommen
ihre einzige hoffnung die flucht durch
die wälder bei nacht und unter
lebensgefahr denn serbische soldaten
hatten große teile der wege vermied er
hatte glück camil durakovic
inzwischen ist der bürgermeister von
srebrenica und schirmherr des friedens
marsches er erreicht die wartenden in
porto jerry 150 kilometer war er zu fuß
unterwegs um eine feste barrieren
der zustrom der besucher reißt nicht ab
dem ist sie zwar kaum gewachsen und
jährlich werden es mehr hotels gibt es
nicht die meisten bleiben nur für wenige
stunden
wer nicht mit dem pkw anreist der kommt
mit einem der zahlreichen busse aus
allen städten boston jetzt um die
versorgung kümmert sich das militär
allein die mehr als 6000 teilnehmer des
friedens marshals werden in zelten
untergebracht überraschend viele junge
sind dabei
antonio de marco estrada brasiliens hat
durch das revier oder in einer
kanadischen damen und das macht niemand
an einem kanal schnell haben unternehmer
go nicht besser oder krokusse droht wenn
der motor ohne spezielle entschied am
lagerfeuer kommuniziere video
während dj nasa das muslimische trauer
gebet beginnt füllt sich das
gelenkzentrum sehr schnell erweckt es
den eindruck als verliere man den
überblick
überall an den gräbern versammeln sich
die familien der ermordeten warten dass
die namen der toten verlesen werden
unter ihnen auch hat
[Musik]
ja
damit niemand das st
[Musik]
ritsch ist der oberste geistliche der
bosnischen muslime
er erweist ihren söhnen und ihrer man
die letzte ehre
[Musik]
euro
mitgezählt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nach jeder beerdigung bleibt eine frage
offen wie konnten die vereinten nationen
tatenlos zusehen warum hat die welt
nicht eingegriffen um dieses verbrechen
zu verhindern
sie ist mit sicherheit das schlimmste an
mord nach dem zweiten weltkrieg was dort
passiert ist mit zahlen die eigentlich
unvorstellbar waren in einer art und
weise die wir uns nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg nicht vorstellen konnten viele
der hinterbliebenen fühlen sich alleine
gelassen
sie wollen nur eins gerechtigkeit die
täter sollen gefasst und verurteilt
werden
eine forderung der sich auch
internationale hilfsorganisationen
anschließen es kann nicht sein dass
unrecht zu recht wird zwar so lange bis
diejenigen die das getan haben hier und
das war nicht nur ein oder zwei da viel
mehr vor gericht kommen
und wenn das nicht passiert seit so
vielen jahren unter nur im ansatz
passiert und ihn gedeckt werden dann
verstehe ich dass sie kämpft und auch
weiterhin kämpfen wird bis zum 8
wie so oft sagt das ist immer die frage
offen wer hat sich an meiner familie
vergriffen wer hat wer hat sich gesagt
meine kinder wegnehmen
doraja eberle kennt hat die ja schon
seit jahren bereits 1996 besuchte die
österreicherin srebrenica zum ersten mal
seitdem engagiert sie sich jedes jahr
ist auch sie am 11 juli vor ort wenn so
viele abschied nehmen und auch am tag
danach ist man 50.000 menschen her
24 stunden später ist nicht ein einziger
mensch mehr hier menschen sind wieder
alleine gelassen
man hat irgendwie keine worte ich denke
mir wenn wir es nicht schaffen den
menschen visionen zu geben oder an
visionen zu glauben
dann werden sie immer im eigenen kreis
hier redet jeder nur über politik
geredet jeder nur über den genozid er
redet jeder nur über die vergangenheit
es müssen taten folgen man kann nicht
nur herkommen sondern man muss dann auch
aktiv etwas tun
viele rückkehrer haben keine heimat mehr
ihre häuser sind zerstört
mit dem bau von holzhäusern unterstützt
doraja eberle die vertriebenen will
ihnen eine perspektive geben wissen zu
besuch bei familie alles bei chin
jaklitsch einem dorf 15 kilometer
außerhalb von srebrenica
auch sie wurden einst vertrieben lebten
jahrelang in einem flüchtlingsheim und
bei verwandten in visoko seit vier
monaten sind sie zurück an den ort ihrer
wurzeln nun versuchen sie sich und ihrer
jungen familie ein eigenes leben
aufzubauen
wir versuchen menschen nach hause zu
bringen ich glaube dass jeder der
displaced im eigenen land ist die
sehnsucht hat auf eigenem grund und
boden wieder zurückzukommen
durch dieses haus system haben wir die
möglichkeit menschen den vier tagen
wieder anzusiedeln und gerade junge
menschen unterstützen wir weil wir so
viel hoffnung in diesem land ziehen und
so viel kapital in diesem land ist das
wesentliche an diesen projekten ist der
schlüssel
das ist das erste mal dass sie wieder
etwas haben was sie zu sparen können
wo sie sagen können das ist meins das
ist mein zuhause ich kann entscheiden ob
jemand zu mir hinein kommt oder nicht
das kann ich in einem zelt nicht das
kann ich in einem container nicht das
kann ich in einem kollektiv center nicht
hier in jacques lüthy hatten sich schon
vor dem krieg land ein stück heimat in
der stadt sei das junge ehepaar keine
zukunft ein stück hoffnung sogar ein
wenig idylle die initiative bauern
helfen bauern möchte starthilfe leisten
das leben gestalten müssen die
rückkehrer selbst wir haben von anfang
an versucht die menschliche würde hierzu
erhalten wir können den menschen nichts
zurückgeben was sie verloren haben
aber wir bemühen uns unsere versprechen
zu halten
[Musik]
eine eigene zukunft für die junge
familie alles scheint dass sie zu geben
in srebrenica
[Musik]
das ist unsere mitverantwortung in die
zukunft zu schauen und in dem sie nicht
die vergangenheit zu vergessen das kann
man nie vergessen aber zu vergeben dann
könnten wir hier die welt verändern
austreiben zu harley pasternak kommen
lassen damals war
[Musik]
zusammen mit primacom apple aperture